of the United States the mistakes
misadventures and shortcomings of Barack
Obama's second term in office for one
night they became opportunities for the
president to get a laugh Obama admitted
it had been a bad year referring to a
gaffe made by his 2012 challenger Mitt
Romney who said forty-seven percent of
Americans would vote for the president
no matter what the forty-seven percent
called Mitt Romney to apologize he also
joked about the technical glitches that
have plagued the rollout of the
government's health care policy in 2008
my slogan was yes we can in 2013 my
slogan was control-alt-delete it seemed
no topic was off-limits he even made
light of the scandal surrounding
government surveillance of US citizens
Colorado legalized marijuana this year
an interesting social experiment I do
hope it doesn't lead to a whole lot of
paranoid people who think that the
federal government's out to get them and
listening to their phone calls
that would be a problem the president's
popularity may be low but on this
evening at least he got the last laugh